there is a new aspect mandatory aspect
of the curriculum in New York City
Schools this would be mindful breathing
say today New York city mayor and
Department of Education Chancellor and
New York City Health commissioner
announced that all New York City Schools
will be required to offer mindful
breathing practices the announcement
aims to increase physical and mental
health and enhance social emotional
learning it means that Eastern
specifically Buddhist religious rituals
and prayers are now a mandatory part of
the curriculum
meaning mindfulness of breathing paying
attention to breath it is the
quintessential form of Buddhist
Meditation attributed to gotama Buddha
and described in several sutas most
notably the anapanasatisute which I
guess makes sense now you might say well
Michael no it's just a coincidence we
mean it's just a coincidence no they're
just teaching breathing exercises
they're not just we all know how to
breathe okay and they're not they
already have gym class what is mindful
breathing well the question you have to
ask is mindful of what